[Musique]
mallet des mutualités le parti
socialiste tient son congrès national
sous la présidence de monsieur du pru
même si nous avions cru à la victoire
finale vie claire nous n'aurions jamais
songé une minute à collaborer avec
l'envahisseur car la force même la plus
irrésistible aurait pu nous contraindre
à nous déshonorer que l'aîné meyer
secrétaire général du parti
quelle a été notre position à l'égard de
gaulle très simple nous qui sommes fiers
d'être et avec quelle affectueuse
reconnaissance le parti de léon blum
notre honneur et notre drapeau
nous n'avons pas depuis 1940
cc un seul instinct de considérer le
général de gaulle comme au seul chef du
gouvernement légitime de l'accord
[Musique]